PRESENTER: All right.
Welcome, everyone, and thanks
for coming to this talk.
My name's [INAUDIBLE]
Hudsley, obviously, and I'm
actually very happy to
introduce today's talk and to
have helped in arranging it.
Actually, Leslie, thank you for
really doing everything
and for enabling us to have
a special showing.
Who has seen the movie?
I assume pretty much everyone,
all right?
And so it's great to have
Jeff actually here
to talk about it.
I wanted to say just a few
things why I think it's kind
of particularly interesting for
us, as Google, to host you
today, and I think it's
sort of two parts.
One is that clearly, for us,
renewable energy has been a
topic for a long time and
energy use, et cetera.
We're trying hard in our
corporate operations and in
our data center operations to
save energy and power things
with renewable energy, be that
here with the solar panels on
the roof or in data centers,
where we've done [INAUDIBLE].
And where we also worked
really hard to save,
literally, a factor of two in
terms of the amount of power
required to run a certain
workload.
So that's one kind of sort of
obvious parallel, I think,
over the past few years.
And obviously, as a company,
we're committed to being
carbon neutral, have
been since 2007.
So that clearly is a relevant
sort of comparison.
And the other thing, though,
that struck me when I saw the
movie was that I think it's
really striking that climate
change is something you
can't really grasp
This is abstract concept.
And the movie does really an
excellent job in sort of
translating to that something
that you can see, right?
Translating something that
really doesn't have an easy
way for you to relate
to it, right?
And this is the first time
that I've seen a really
compelling way of seeing
what actually happens.
And this morning, actually, I
had an interview with two
journalists, and they're
writing a story.
And their story is about where
the internet lives.
And the internet, actually, has
kind of the same property.
Like everyone uses it,
like climate, right?
Everyone's affected by it.
But it's actually not very
graspable, right?
You see your laptop and it's
connected to your internet,
but, like, you actually don't
see anything else.
Maybe you see a Wi-Fi router
somewhere and a cable coming
out from it.
But that's kind of, for most
people, the end of the
understanding really where the
internet really lives, right?
And so making that visible was
actually, last year, the goal
of our where the internet lives
data center site, like,
with the pictures, et cetera.
And we got a lot of response,
too, where people said, oh,
finally, I can actually kind of
understand, visually, what
happens when I use
the internet.
So lots of parallels.
So let me briefly
introduce Jeff.
I got to go look at my notes.
Jeff Orlowski.
I think most of you have
seen the screening.
If you haven't seen the
screening, it's still playing
in a number of theaters,
and I saw it in
Palo Alto before Christmas.
And Jeff won the Excellence in
Cinematography Award at the
Sundance Film Festival, a
premiere, obviously, festival
for independent movies.
And if you've seen the
movie, you know why.
It really is just visually
stunning and, at the same
time, moving in more
than one way.
And so I'm very happy
that he's here.
His work, obviously, has
helped lots of people.
I don't know, do you have your
count of, like, how many
people have seen the movie?
JEFF ORLOWSKI: We're
working on that.
I don't have an explicit
count.
PRESENTER: So my guess would
be at least hundreds of
thousands of people
already see it.
JEFF ORLOWSKI: Yeah, easily.
PRESENTER: The trailer
on YouTube is
actually very popular.
It's a four-minute trailer
on YouTube.
So I'm very pleased here to have
Jeff Orlowski, and please
[INAUDIBLE].
JEFF ORLOWSKI: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JEFF ORLOWSKI: Thank
you very much.
Thanks for having--
we're using the [INAUDIBLE],
right, not this one?
Thank you, guys, very
much for being here.
I went to Stanford.
I spent a bunch of time here
during undergrad, and it's
just really cool to
be back on campus.
On campus, this isn't
my campus.
But yeah, we're just thrilled
to have the opportunity to
share the film with you guys and
that you got a chance to
see the film yesterday.
It's something where we went
into this without really
knowing what we were
going to do.
We didn't go into it with
the intention of
making a film, in fact.
When I first met James, the
goal was really just to
document him and to document
his project.
But I'll kind of get
into that with some
images in a little bit.
I've got a bunch of photographs
here that I wanted
to show and kind of keep it free
form, and then we'll kind
of jump into Q and A's
pretty quickly.
So I want to try and address any
kind of questions you guys
have as soon as possible.
If you haven't had a chance to
see the film, this is the
whole film right here.
That's the final
cut time line.
That's not all of the audio
tracks, in fact.
I think we ended up getting
into, like, the 20s or 30s in
terms of the number
of audio tracks.
And I just took a screen grab
of this one day and I showed
it to some friends, and then
realized this is the
complexity that goes into
the editing process.
And the more impressive thing,
just conceptually, is that
each one of those lines, each
one of those slices, is
another creative decision that
you have to make in the
process of editing the film.
It is, in part, very technical,
but at the same
time, it's artistic, and you
have to make all these
decisions on the fly.
And there's, literally, an
infinite number of ways you
can edit a film.
We spent three years editing
"Chasing Ice." There's some
reasons and some stories as to
why it took that long and some
of the concepts that we were
shifting as we went through
the development of the film,
but we can save that for
later, if you want.
I'm going to show the
trailer real fast.
Just in case anybody hasn't
seen it, it's a short,
two-minute, little trailer
for the film.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I'm on the phone with Jim on
one of our regular check-ins.
Like, Jim, nothing's
happening.
-It's starting, Adam, I think.
Adam, it's starting.
-Look at that.
Look at the whole face.
-It all started in Iceland.
-I think I'm so certain to get
wet, I'll take my boots off.
-I never imagined that you could
see glaciers this big
disappearing in such
a short time.
There's a powerful piece of
history that's unfolding in
these pictures, and
I have to go back.
The initial goal was to put
out 25 cameras for three
years, shoot every hour as long
as it was daylight that
would show you how the landscape
was changing.
-Ah, this is the way to
travel, my friend.
-Putting really delicate
electronics in the harshest
conditions on the planet.
-It's not the nicest environment
for technology.
-I do not want to go any
lower than this.
It's just bottomless.
-I'm going out here on this
broken fin, and I assume it
won't collapse.
-Every once in a while,
I hear the same,
what were you thinking?
Maybe that office job
wasn't so bad.
This thing is just rock.
-It's not working.
God.
-All of that obsession means
nothing if it doesn't work.
-Just be careful.
Don't get too close to
the edge, all right?
-This is terrifying.
-This knee's had two surgeries,
really could use a third.
-He goes to that point where
he can't anymore, and
sometimes he's going further.
-We have low oil pressure
in Engine #2,
-This is big stuff.
-I think right now.
-OK, onward.
-This is the memory
of the landscape.
That landscape is gone.
It may never be seen again in
the history of civilization,
and it's stored right here.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So I just saw the reference
to the original
song that we had scored.
The film has just been nominated
for an Academy Award
in the category of Best
Original Song.
We're actually trying to get
Scarlett Johansson, who
performed the song, trying
to get her to do a live
performance at the Academy
Awards, which would be really
awesome if we can pull that
off, but we're trying to
figure that out.
So as [INAUDIBLE] was saying
earlier, what James was really
trying to do was to create a
visualization of climate
change from his perspective.
He's a photographer.
He was out in the field.
He saw these landscapes
changing, and he wanted to
figure out how could he, as a
photographer, use his skills
and tools to make this happen.
And in the process--
and you can kind of get a sense
of it for the feel that
we were going for with
the trailer--
we didn't want this to be a very
science-heavy film about
climate change.
In fact, at the beginning, we
didn't want it to be about
climate change at all.
We were really considering it
a film about a photographer.
We called it "The Photographer."
It was about
James's entire life's work
and a lot of different
photographic projects
that he had done
over his whole career.
And we were using the story of
the ice as a through line,
effectively.
And in the editing process, we
realized that we needed to
shift that.
And we wanted to switch that
around to make it much more
focused on the Extreme Ice
Survey and what James
accomplished with these
time lapses.
But it brings up the issue of,
how do you communicate climate
change to the public?
And this is something that we
spent a lot of time thinking
about because we didn't want
to approach it as though,
here's a science-heavy film.
You're going to sit and be
lectured to and listen to
experts, talking heads,
about the issue.
We really tried to frame it in
terms of the adventure and the
experience that we had.
Now when we first set
off, that wasn't
really the goal at all.
Like I said, we weren't planning
on making a film.
James wanted to set up these
time-lapse cameras, put them
out there, and just document
what was going on.
And I met James when I was
a junior at Stanford.
The project was getting started
when I was a senior,
and I had the fortune of joining
him and going out into
the field with him.
And my role was just
to shoot video.
That was the intention
at the beginning.
So somebody else shot
this time lapse.
This is a time lapse of the
camera being built, so a time
lapse of the time lapse.
But this is something that was
founded in his garage.
He had random parts from the
hardware store that he put
together, and he built something
that he thought
could be installed and would,
hopefully, last for a long
period of time.
And the first trip that
we did to Iceland--
it was in March of 2007--
it was a team of these six guys,
and we had the cameras
that James had designed
out in the field.
And we got to Iceland.
We had these tripods.
We were going to mount
them to the ground.
We were going to secure
them with guy wires.
And when we got there,
we realized the
ground was way too soft.
The cameras wouldn't be, like,
they wouldn't stay sturdy.
Like, we were going to hardware
stores, trying to
find lumber so that we could
build a bracket that could be
mounted to the wall.
And you couldn't find
pressure-treated lumber in Iceland.
And then everything was metric
units, and all of our tools
didn't work.
It was just all these seemingly
small, easy, little,
minuscule details were really
putting the whole project into
jeopardy from the very, very
first installation in Iceland.
And, ultimately, we found
enough parts at
the hardware store.
We were able to jury-rig
a system, and we
installed the cameras.
And those rigs have been
out there now--
with a bunch of problems and
rockfalls and interruptions in
the process-- but they've
been out there now for
just about six years.
In two more months, it'll have
been six years of photography
that we've captured.
But this is--
I had very short hair
back then--
back in March of 2007.
The goal, from my perspective,
was just to follow James and
to document what he was doing.
The video was intended for
YouTube videos, for
promotional materials for him
to help get funds raised by
showing people what
he was doing.
And we weren't planning
on making a film.
But for me, it was just being
23 years old and having the
opportunity to go to Greenland,
and then having the
chance to go to Iceland and get
to shoot and explore these
landscapes.
That's what got me hooked on it,
and that's why I wanted to
work with him in the
first place.
And it wasn't until about a
year and a half into the
project, where James had been
doing a lot of lectures.
He had been showing the time
lapses at that point, and we
were seeing the response
from audiences.
Between the response from the
audience of the power of the
time-lapse photography combined
with over 100 hours
of video footage that we had
collected at that point, we
knew that we had the materials
to go ahead and
start making a film.
So that's when I really started
pushing James heavily.
Give me the green light.
Let me make the film.
He didn't want to be the
subject of the film.
You know, he's a guy who's
normally behind the camera,
and he's the one who wants to
take pictures of other things.
So the whole time, he was always
reluctant to be in
front of the camera.
It was uncomfortable for him.
He got used to it over time.
He got comfortable with--
just when the camera's there
that often and always filming
him, you kind of have
to get used to it.
So that was the upside.
But finally, he recognized
the potential and
the value for a film.
Gave me the green light.
And we started building a team,
and we started going
ahead and editing it.
I just want to show a bunch
of other images out in the
fields, some of the stuff that's
not in the film, and
try and give you some anecdotes
behind some of the
key events that happened.
But one of the most amazing
things for me was going ice
climbing for the first time.
I had done a lot of
outdoor stuff.
I had done a lot of camping
and done a lot of rock
climbing, but never
ice climbing.
So you're wearing crampons,
these huge, spike things that
will secure you on the ice,
and you're using these ice
axes and climbing around.
And this one flank right here,
that's the very first piece of
ice I ever climbed.
And it was an incredible--
like, it was so much fun.
I was so thrilled just by having
this completely new
experience of your hands and
your feet attaching to a wall
in a different way.
And a couple months after we
were in this landscape taking
these photographs, we
got the update from
the time-lapse camera.
And this landscape here, all of
the dark ice, the black ice
here with all the dirt on it,
it's called dead ice, and the
white behind it is the actual
main glacier that's flowing.
So if you imagine, the
glacier's flowing.
It's going next to
the mountainside.
And what happens, a lot of the
darkness is debris from the
glacier kind of scraping
the mountain and it
falling onto the ice.
But then, sometimes, there are
these little eddies that are
frozen in place, and
they're not flowing
with the regular glacier.
So they call that dead
ice, and it's old.
It's pretty stable.
And all of this in the
foreground was that dead ice.
And a couple months after this,
we got the images from
the time-lapse camera, and all
of this had disappeared.
I mean, this entire landscape
that we had spent days and
days climbing on, exploring
those, like, first experiences
ice climbing, it was all gone.
And the realization that these
landscapes are changing that
fast in such a big fashion,
that was a huge
revelation for me.
So the cameras are out there,
and we look at them as our
little sentinels, our little
R2D2s, shooting every-- now
they're shooting every half
hour of daylight.
So 18 minutes ago, we had 34
cameras around the world turn
their sensor on, check to see
if there's enough light.
The timers that we designed,
that we redesigned in the
process of working on improving
the technology, the
timer has a light
sensor in it.
And that's allowing the system
to save a lot of power in the
long, cold winters that
have no daylight.
So it checks to see if there's
enough light, will turn the
camera system on.
It'll take one exposure.
It'll wait 30 seconds and
put the whole thing into
hibernation and wait for the
next half hour to take the
next photograph.
Originally, the camera boxes
were all grey because we were
concerned about vandalism.
We were concerned that, in
Iceland, there are places
where people can come.
They might steal the cameras.
There's a warning on the
back of the camera box.
And we installed a bunch
of these grey cameras.
And then we got to certain
places, and we couldn't find
them when we were looking
for them.
We were, like, flying around in
a helicopter trying to find
the camera.
So, ultimately, we switched to
these orange camera boxes for
the very remote ones, which
made a big difference in
spotting them in these
landscapes.
But this here is another shot
from that Columbia Glacier.
And this here, the dead ice that
I was referencing, is in
this foreground.
This glacier has now retreated
all the way back to that
mountain ridge, and it's split
into two separate glaciers.
So now there are two different
branches to the Columbia
Glacier, and that's all
documented from that camera
right there.
This camera, it's been panned.
In the film, it's the one that
was panned a couple of times.
And this one has also been
moved, as well, to a location
to continue the record.
This next shot is from an
iceberg that calved off the
Columbia Glacier, so that's
the same kind of
island in the back.
And this here--
this was even shot in
the summertime--
but it's so backed up with ice
that, although this is the
surface of the Atlantic
Ocean--
sorry, the Pacific Ocean--
it's filled with icebergs
all the way back.
So that is the surface of the
Pacific Ocean, all those
icebergs that are kind
of stuck in there.
And this was one of the stupider
things that we did,
one of the riskier things, but
because these pieces of ice do
roll over, and they'll break
and roll at any given time.
So we had a helicopter.
We flew around.
We put Adam on the
piece of ice.
He had a walkie-talkie.
If he wanted to bail at any
moment, he could've just
called us and said, I'm done.
And we tried to keep it
really, really quick.
We did a couple of passes,
filming Adam on the piece of
ice and photographing
it as well.
And the reason why he's there
is for scale, and it's
something that we talked
about in the film.
And it's something that's
really, really difficult to
communicate in these landscapes
because they are
far larger than anything you
can possibly experience
in the Lower 48.
I've been to Glacier
National Park.
We installed cameras there.
It doesn't compare whatsoever
to Glacier National Park.
These landscapes are huge.
And the only way you can get a
sense of how big they are is
through some scale reference.
So we would regularly try to
put people in, boats or
helicopters or any sort of human
reference that gives you
a sense of it.
On the Greenland Ice
Sheet, which we
filmed for quite a bit--
it's in the middle of the film
where it's the landscape of
literally just ice in
all directions--
that's all you see.
There's no wildlife.
There's no plants whatsoever.
There's algae, which is the
only other living matter
whatsoever.
And then all you hear is the
sound of wind and the sound of
water as it's running across
the surface of the
Greenland Ice Sheet.
The only way you can get
there is by helicopter.
We did spend quite a bit of time
in the helicopter to get
to these locations because
that's the only
way you can get there.
And when that helicopter takes
off, and you're there with
your pile of gear and you hear
the choppers fading off in the
distance, it's a very,
very lonely feeling.
You have the full deep
appreciation for the fact that
you've got a limited
set of resources.
You've got limited supplies.
It's you and three
other people.
And your survival is based on
you guys being able to work
together, trust each other, make
sure your food and your
fuel and everything lasts for
the time that you need it to.
We've been out on the Greenland
Ice Sheet and at
other places in Greenland, where
we get stuck there due
to bad weather.
Even times when the weather is
crystal-clear blue skies just
like this, they call us from
the airport and say, it's
foggy here.
We can't take off.
And there were times where I
almost missed my graduation
because we were delayed a day
of helicopter flights.
James was stuck in Greenland for
five days one time because
they couldn't get the
helicopter to him.
The way they do their scheduling
there, if you miss
your time slot, they put you
at the end of the list.
So they do all the other
reservations, and then they
come and get you at the
next available slot.
Not really ideal, but certainly
when you're, like,
down to your last couple packets
of food, but it always
worked out in the end.
But they do give you access to
incredible places that you
would not be able to
see anywhere else.
And once again, imagine
what this place--
what it would look like without
Adam standing there,
without that scale reference.
I actually was just thinking of
Photoshopping him out just
to show the picture first
and just imagining
what it looks like.
And then when you see
the human scale, it
really changes things.
The black stuff at the bottom,
if you remember from the film,
it's that stuff called
cryonkonite.
So that is soot.
It's black carbon.
It's a lot of other dust and
pollutants, along with
meteorite dust and some dust
from, kind of, Asia
that gets blown in.
And that's causing the ice to
melt faster, but it also
creates these really,
really beautiful
landscapes and features.
This is where we shot in that
moulin in the film, and this
was one of the days where
we were scouting it.
The photo looks rather
treacherous and, like, I could
just slide right off,
but I felt secure
at the time, I recall.
You can just barely make out, on
the right-hand side at the
top, a couple little dots,
little, black dots.
So those are people standing
up there who
were setting up anchors.
We had gone to that side.
We hiked around and came to this
side of the moulin, and
we assessed from this
side as well.
And we decided we were going to
shoot from there for better
lighting conditions and the way
the light would come in
through the canyon.
We set the anchors up
on the first day.
We set all the anchors
up in triplicate.
So you see a bit of that in
the film, where there's a
drill that goes in and two
different drill holes are
made, and they're connected.
And it's called a V-thread.
And if you go ice climbing,
typically you would do that
with a six-inch or an eight-inch
deep ice screw, and
you would make a connection
like that.
But in respect for James's
paranoia, we used these
one-meter long drills, and we
had them in triplicate.
So those columns of ice could
haul a lot of weight.
You could pull a car up
with those anchors.
So one person was tied into
those three separate anchors
on one rope.
And then you have a second rope
going to a belayer, who
is also tied into another
set of three anchors.
And whenever people went down,
certainly over the hole
itself, they had two ropes.
In some other cases, because
we only had four people, if
three of us were down at the
same time we took some other
precautions.
But when you're there with
only one rope, it is
significantly dangerous.
You swing your ice axe the wrong
way and you hit that
rope, you're in some pretty
deep trouble.
So you have to be very, very
careful and conscious when
you're climbing on ice, how
you're using the tools, where
you're walking.
You can't just step around and
walk normally because if your
crampon steps on the rope,
that rope is damaged.
It's very, very vulnerable.
So you have to be paranoid
about those things.
James has lost a lot of friends
out in the wilderness
due to light aircraft accidents
and also climbing
accidents, where people--
they're walking and their
crampon hits the inside of
their pant leg, and they
trip and fall and
you go off a cliff.
It's also a very easy
to get confused--
not get confused, but have a
false sense of security from
the camera because you're
shooting, and you're like, oh,
I can go up to the edge here.
This is safe.
And actually I need to be
a little bit closer.
And there was one time I was
standing on this ice bridge,
and there was another piece of
ice right in front of me.
And I thought it was pinned on
the beach, and I thought I
could step on it securely.
And so I've got the camera in my
hand, and I shift my weight
over, and I'm shifting.
And once I committed my weight,
I felt the ice start
to sink underneath my foot.
And I'm holding the camera and
I've got these huge rain
slickers on, and it's totally
bulky and I can't move
effectively, and I start
feeling myself
sinking into the water.
I slide off the ice bridge and
completely going up to my neck
in ice water.
I took the camera.
I like turned, I saved
the camera.
I put it on where
I was standing.
It was, like, the
top priority.
And then I, like, struggled
and climbed out.
That was one of the first
trips to Alaska.
What I didn't even know
or didn't even
realize at the time--
that was actually the scene
where James, he's holding up
the memory card, and he's,
like, the memory of the
landscape is stored
right here.
It may be gone forever,
but it's stored here.
I shot that while I had these
cotton base layers on, which I
didn't even know, at the time,
you shouldn't be wearing
cotton or whatever.
I was freezing the whole
day, shivering.
And when we got back to the
little motel we were staying
at, I was peeling these
layers off.
James saw me take off, like, a
regular pair of jeans and a
cotton T-shirt.
And he started yelling at me,
what are you doing wearing
this stuff?
You need to wear
fleece or wool.
So you learn those
lessons quickly.
Yeah.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JEFF ORLOWSKI: I mean, I was
surprised by how effective the
rain slickers were at
keeping heat in.
They were very, very heavy,
and they're waterproof and
they're very insulated.
So it did a surprisingly good
job of keeping that in.
But separate from that, we were
just running around the
whole time, and then I filmed
him for a little bit.
We were hiking around.
We got back into the canoes
pretty soon, and we were
paddling back.
And once we got in the car, it
was, like, blast the heater.
So all that was fun.
But anyway, so we spent a lot
of time in this landscape
making sure that everything
was safe and secure.
And we went down there the first
day of shooting, and
James got his photographs.
I got my video.
And I had some problems
with the video.
I had set the camera to
autofocus because I wasn't
sure what the camera would see
looking down into that hole.
And so I set it like that.
We got back to the tent that
night, and we were reviewing
the photographs and James
didn't like his stuff.
And I looked at my photos--
the video-- and I saw that the
camera had focused on the
water droplets on the lens.
The waterfall had put all this
mist and moisture on the lens,
and I had really beautiful
photographs
of these water droplets.
And everything beyond was just
blurry, out of focus,
completely out of focus.
So James said that he wanted
to go back the next day
because he wasn't happy
with his photos.
I was perfectly fine
with that.
I wanted to get some
more video myself.
So we ended up spending three
days shooting down there.
This is a photo that I took
of James when he went
down there as well.
And ultimately-- you guys
remember some of the footage
that was from this scene--
it's one of my favorite
scenes in the film.
All the credit has to go to
James for figuring this out,
but it's a place where you can
very visually tell the story
of climate change, or you can
take the concept of how this
ice is melting and
how it's being
transferred to the ocean.
This is one of those key places
where it's happening.
This is how it's happening,
and he was able to make a
photograph.
And in the same process, the
adventure was compelling
enough that it's been a very
strong scene in the film.
Another big scene was the
big glacier calving.
Where this here is from the
Llulissat Glacier, where Adam
and I spent--
we were planning to spend about
a month, three to four
weeks camped out there, and on
day 17 is when the calving
actually happened.
This is another location
but just showing
some more of the cameras.
The two of us maintained
a 24-hour vigil.
So we had three eight-hour
shifts, and we would be up
together for eight hours.
And then I would have the night
shift, up until, like,
five or six--
I forget, like the wee early
hours in the morning.
And then Adam had the morning
shift, and then we were up for
dinner again every day.
In the summertime in May in
Greenland, you have 24 hours
of daylight.
So if there was a big calving
event that happened at 2:00
AM, we wanted somebody
awake to capture it.
Because of the distance to the
glacier-- we were about two
miles away from the glacier--
you don't necessarily hear
when something starts to
happen all the time.
That's typically the first
indicator, when you do hear a
large pop or noise or rumble,
and that's when you would
stick your head out
of the tent and
start checking on things.
But many times, we had
discovered, we
would be at a glacier.
We'd have a time-lapse
camera set up.
We'd spend the whole
day working.
We would think that nothing
happened to the glacier.
We'd review the time lapse
footage and see that a bunch
of pieces broke off, and the
glacier had advanced a whole
lot and we didn't
recognize it.
We didn't see it happen
with our own eyes.
And even on that short period
of time, it's amazing to see
how the cameras can capture
something that you can't
experience yourself.
And so we really tried to keep
a very ongoing vigil going.
In the middle of the night, I
was definitely in the tent
more often than not.
It was still very, very cold.
This is one of the tents that
we used for all of our gear.
We had a kind of communal
tent, and then
each of us had a tent.
And then this was the
gear tent with--
the orange cable is a long
extension cord coming from our
little 1,000 watt generator,
which powered the computers,
the whole rat's nest of charges
for all the cameras,
all the hard drives.
This case here carried four
terabytes worth of data in
eight 500-gigabyte-powered
hard drives.
We couldn't afford to get
a whole bunch of small,
portable, bus-powered drives at
the time, so they were all
wall-powered units.
It was a suitcase that was very,
very carefully padded
and protected.
It was, like, this is
the thing that we're
guarding with our lives.
And it was a very heavy case
with all those hard drives.
But this is, basically,
all the sensitive
gear in this tent.
Always having backups of every
single piece of electronic
gear, spare cameras.
We had nine cameras on this
particular trip for video and
five time-lapse cameras, my
computer and Adam's computer.
Just the level of redundancy was
really, really important
for this trip.
I think we're just about
out of time.
There's not much more.
The film has been really
well-received at a lot of
different festivals.
It's been getting out there.
We've won about 30
awards right now.
As I mentioned, the Academy
Award nomination as well.
We have launched an iOS app that
came out about a couple
weeks ago, maybe
two months ago.
We're going to be putting a lot
more photos and video and
content on there, trying to keep
that updated and figuring
out a lot more ways just to
keep the imagery going and
keep it alive online.
Really, the time lapses are
continuing to shoot.
And as James updates the time
lapses, we want to make those
available to the public, so
they can see them and
interact with them.
And in the iOS app, you can,
like, scrub your finger back
and forth and see the glacier
moved forward
and backward in time.
So I just wanted to close with
a couple of other photos.
This here, we call it kissing
bergs, and this is from a
location in Greenland by
the Llulissat Glacier.
And those are some very, very
massive pieces of ice.
It's one of my favorite shots
from the collection.
And this shot here is from a
beach in Iceland, and it's
interesting because James fell
in love with this landscape.
There are these black--
just black sand beaches.
And when you're walking around
and you see these crystal
pieces of ice sitting on the
beach, it looks like a diamond
on the beach.
And he did a whole series
of photographs that
he calls ice diamonds.
We would shoot at night.
He would backlight them.
They would just be glowing,
really, really
spectacularly-lit
pieces of ice.
In one of the time lapses, the
nighttime scene in the film,
there's a first shot where
you see this--
I call it space berg--
it's this glowing
piece of ice.
And James actually used that
technique of lighting it from
behind to get that effect, and
we used that in some of the
night time lapses as well.
But it really was discovered
on this beach where--
he calls it the place where
the ice goes to die.
It's part of that cycle.
It's part of that kind of
mortality theme that he was
kind of reflective about, and
it's something that always
left a strong impression on me,
seeing these pieces of ice
melting away.
That's it in terms of what I
wanted to share with you guys,
and I'd love to answer any
questions that you might have.
We do have wireless mics
to record all of it.
Thank you guys very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So going back to the main
calving event, I know you said
that you were about
two miles away.
How did it feel like it was
getting closer once the ice
started to turn over?
And then my other question is,
was there a plan B if nothing
had happened within the month
that you were planning?
JEFF ORLOWSKI: Yes.
The plan B was that
we wouldn't have
gotten anything, really.
And we were wanting to wait
for as long as we possibly
could, but you can't predict
those things.
It was a trip where Adam and I
went, we donated our time to
go out there.
And it was a $40,000 trip to
send two guys to the middle of
Nowhere, Greenland and to keep
us alive for a month.
So the expenses were really,
really high.
There was no other
real option.
We were a bit strategic in that
we went to a different
glacier first, and then we went
to the Llulissat Glacier.
And so we were really trying
to figure out between these
two glaciers, optimizing the
opportunity to capture something.
At the Store Glacier, we did
capture a small calving event
that we thought was valuable.
If nothing else happened, that
was a pretty decent one.
But we still wanted to go to
the bigger glacier, the
Llulissat Glacier, with the
hopes of capturing something
much larger.
And quite honestly, it was
just serendipity, and the
timing worked out well.
We had the knowledge of an
entire year's worth of
photography prior to that, so
we knew what happened to the
glacier in the year earlier.
And typically, the scientists
are aware that there are
spring break-ups.
So typically, in the May period
of time, is when the
glacier would have
calving events.
Everything is kind of thawing
out from the spring.
Things are thawing out.
That's when the glacier's
starting to pick
up some speed again.
That bay, in particular, starts
clearing out around
that time, so we were really
trying to aim around spending
that time in May
to capture it.
It still was far bigger
than anything
we expected to capture.
Your other question again?
AUDIENCE: You were two
miles away but--
JEFF ORLOWSKI: Oh, distance So
we were on solid bedrock.
We were very, very safe
where we were.
There was no risk
of the glacier
affecting us at that location.
It would actually take about a
half hour to hike from where
we were standing to where the
glacier was, where the dead
ice begins, where we would
even be at any risk
whatsoever, and part of that
was so that we could get a
better vantage.
We wanted to be in a spot where
we could look down at
the glacier to get a better
perspective on it.
And we zoomed the camera lenses
in all the way we could
to capture it, but that's how
we were able to capture it.
That said, the dead ice next
to that glacier is another
place where we spent
a lot of time.
We had cameras mounted there up
until the day prior to the
calving event, trying
to capture things
on a smaller scale.
And it was interesting because,
from those time
lapses, you could see the
glacier flowing in the
background, but the ice in the
foreground was stagnant, and
you can see kind of the
relationship of those two
different sections of ice.
But we were very safe.
I'll just add one other comment
about that in regards
to the sound.
A lot of people ask questions
about the
sound for the calving.
Because we were so far away,
the actual audio that we
captured on our cameras
was very poor.
There's a lot of wind noise.
There's a lot of distance.
There's also a lot of us yelling
and screaming and
being, like, ridiculously
excited that finally something
was happening.
And the way it's cut
in the film is
exactly how it happened.
We were on the phone
with James.
We were doing a regular check
in, just giving him an update.
And during the phone
call is when the
glacier started to move.
We called him back three or four
times during the span of
the calving event, just
giving him an update.
It's been 20 minutes.
It's still happening.
You won't believe
it, it's huge.
40 minutes, it's still
happening.
So we called him a bunch of
times to give him the updates,
and we could definitely feel
that James was upset that he
wasn't there watching
it himself.
He's, like, back in the
office in Boulder,
like, why am I here?
But the audio came from
three main sources.
We used audio that we had
captured from other calving
events where we were
a lot closer.
So typically, in Alaska, and
then also in other places in
Greenland, we were much close
to the glacier and got very
good sound from the calving.
The second main source is from
Skywalker, in that they have
an incredible library of
ice-calving sounds.
Skywalker Sound, that's why
they're the best in the world.
They've done a bunch of
projects, where Ben Burtt has
gone out to Alaska to film ice
calving, and they had a great
library for that.
And the third thing was
kind of interesting.
Some of the scientists that we
worked, they use this device
called a seismometer,
which anybody in
California is aware of.
That's what's used to
measure earthquakes.
So they mount it to the bedrock,
and the device can
pick up any vibration
on the planet.
And it will pick up--
they call them ice quakes,
when the glacier lurches
forward or when a calving
event happens--
the scientists can tell how
violent the shaking was, the
rumbling was.
And they can take that
information in those waves,
and they can convert
it into sound.
And you can actually hear the
sound of the planet shaking
when the ice is calving.
And we had the sound from that
exact event, and we worked
that into the film as well
to mix it into there.
AUDIENCE: Did you feel
any rumbling?
JEFF ORLOWSKI: At that distance,
we didn't feel any
distinct rumbling.
I can't recall.
I don't think Adam would
say that he did either.
In part because of the noise
and the wind and everything
else and just the distraction
of, are the cameras running?
Make sure, all right, batteries
and memory cards.
And hold on, we have
to swap a tape.
And you're so distracted with
all of that that we didn't
have that much opportunity
to really just--
I think we both tried to milk
those real experiences of,
like, holy crap, look at what's
happening, and we're
the only two people here.
But it was also actively
working hard.
AUDIENCE: This is such an
enormous project, both in
topic and in terms of all the
hours that were, probably,
filmed, thousands of hours.
How do you even take something
so enormous and begin editing
it, begin, like, having it
all tie in together?
It seems so intimidating to me
to think about it, but how did
your project?
JEFF ORLOWSKI: Thank
you for that.
I think it's something that both
James and I experienced
many times over the course of
the project, and a number of
times where we both felt like,
OK, it's time to give up or
should we give up or why are
we doing this to ourselves.
It was one of those scenarios
where, to some degree,
ignorance is bliss.
And had I known how difficult
it would have been at the
beginning, I'd like to think
that I would have wanted to
still do it.
But it was so, so hard.
I think from James's
perspective, the biggest
struggle for him was the
technology not working and the
constant struggle for
funding and keeping
the whole thing alive.
It was incredibly difficult for
him to fund the project.
It was hard for us to fund
the film as well.
It was all friends and family
who paid for the film and a
lot of donated time that
kept it going.
But it was really one of those
things where we felt a
responsibility to get
it out there.
We knew that we needed to get it
out there, and we just had
to figure out, how could
we get to that goal?
The beginning processes for
the editing was very
difficult, and I worked with a
writer who helped to give me a
structure to work with.
And he and I were talking
through what we wanted from a
big-picture perspective.
And we decided, here's a scene,
or we're going to cut
this one scene, and
we tried it.
And then we cut another scene,
and OK, that was good.
And probably the first
half-dozen scenes that we cut
aren't in the film
at all anymore.
It had gone through so
many iterations.
But it was really trying to
tackle it scene by scene,
trying to keep one specific goal
in mind that's tangible
that you can accomplish.
This is what we want
to do today.
It's just this one thing.
And really, all those million
steps add up.
Yes?
Do we need the microphone?
We have the microphone
over there.
We'll get the mic down here.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I just wanted to hear about--
the film's so powerful.
As you've been showing it to
political leaders, what type
of response you've
been getting.
And a small, just technical
question in how you decided on
the interval for the lapse.
JEFF ORLOWSKI: Yeah.
So the intervals were based on,
how many could we possibly
milk out before the memory
cards ran out of space?
OK, are we going to get back
to this camera in a year?
Are we going to get back
here in two years?
Using 32-gigabyte cards, with
calculating how many photos it
would take.
We started off doing one
every hour, and that
was kind of the rubric.
As the memory cards got larger
and larger in capacity, as the
system became more reliable,
we upped that
to every half hour.
If we were there with the
cameras, where when Adam and I
are shooting or the whole team
is shooting something, we
would set the cameras to shoot
very, very quickly, in some
cases, every five minutes
watching the glacier.
Or, if we were doing kind of
more aesthetic time lapses of
ice moving, they would be
sometimes every second, every
two seconds, every 10 seconds.
So the interval was really
dependent on what we were
trying to capture.
And conceptually, we broke them
up into the long-term
time lapses and short-term
time lapses.
That's the language that
we always used.
Because most people think of
time lapses as a one-hour time
lapse or a one-day-long
time lapse.
And we would do those, but that
wasn't the core project.
So for us, those were all
short-term time lapses.
And then the political response
to the film has been
interesting.
We did a screening before
Congress, which doesn't mean
that all of Congress came
to see the film.
But we did give out DVDs to
every senator and every
congressman in Washington, so
we feel like we upheld some
sense of responsibility
with that.
We've had a very good response
from our senators and
congressmen in Colorado that
we're connected to and have
seen the film and have been
trying to support getting the
film out there.
One of the issues is
that it is such a
political subject, right?
From my perspective as
a filmmaker, making a
documentary about this subject
is particularly challenging.
You can choose a subject where
people don't know anything
about the issue, and they come
in to see the film and they
learn about your issue.
And you can convey whatever you
want, and they leave the
film learning more about
that subject.
Here, everybody comes into the
film with the preconceived
notion of climate change,
whether it's happening or
whether it isn't, their stance
on the policy issues, what we
should be doing about it.
So we have this huge, huge
uphill battle to win an
audience over and to get them
to even kind of think about
what we could do next.
We didn't want the film
to be political.
We really tried to keep
that out of the
content of the film.
There are some news clips that
are in the film that are
really just establishing, this
is where we are socially,
culturally.
This is where the conversation
about this issue is happening.
There is still this childlike
debate among some media
outlets as to whether or not it
is or isn't happening, and
we needed that in the film
because that's the only reason
why James did the project
in the first place.
If it wasn't for that lack of
consensus in the public's eye,
not from the scientific
perspective, but from the
public's eye, James would have
had no reason to make the time
lapses in the first place.
So it's been interesting to see
what kind of influence the
film can have in the
political space.
There are more and more groups
that are trying to leverage
the film to advance awareness
about the issue.
We want the film to be used as
a tool for that purpose.
I mean, that's kind of
our mindset now.
Like I said, that wasn't
the intention
when we made the film.
We wanted it to be
James's story.
This is his experience.
This is what he saw.
This is what his cameras
captured.
You can't argue with the
photography, like, this is
what's going on, and you can
make your own assessment as to
what this means from the
long-term perspective.
James's opinion is stated in the
film in regards to that.
But it's something where we
really wanted to give people--
we want the film to be used as
a tool to get the awareness
out there about the issue.
We did a screening before the
United Nations as well.
We haven't done a screening
for Fox News.
We did an interview
with Fox News.
It was expected, but
disappointing, that all of the
questions that they asked were
just about our experience
about the project, about the
aesthetics and the photography
and the adventure.
They didn't ask any questions
about policy or what needs to
be done or why is there a
debate about this issue.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JEFF ORLOWSKI: Did you all
hear the question?
The question was about when we
were out there, how did we
survive psychologically with
the limited resources?
It was surprisingly easy from
my perspective, and I think
most of the team would agree
because we had such a specific
mission all the time.
Well, OK.
There are a couple different
trips, and I guess different
ones fit different categories.
The glacier-watching
trip was unique.
That was the only time where we
were out there, and it was
just me and Adam waiting for
that period of time.
All the other trips,
we were with James.
James had a specific photograph
that he had a
conceptual idea over, and every
day was about trying to
capture that one image.
So we were very occupied with
the work of the photography.
And even that long
glacier-watching trip, we did
bring a very big stack
of books, definitely.
We actually had to agree on
which books we would bring
because we had limited-weight
capacity that we could bring.
So Adam and I, we both had to
sign off on every book that we
took out there.
But you're so busy, like,
cooking for yourself and,
like, keeping yourself fed and
keeping yourself warm and
checking cameras, downloading
cards,
backing up all the data.
You're doing so much of that
to keep the camp life going
and keep the cameras running,
that there were only a couple
hours every day of downtime.
And honestly, like, right now,
I wish I could just be back
out there, and, like, have
some rest and relaxation.
But yeah, it was something
where it wasn't, from my
perspective, it wasn't
that hard to keep
focused on the work.
Yeah?
And we need to pass the
mic around just
for the video stream.
AUDIENCE: Since this
is Google, I'll
ask a technical question.
So I'm actually pretty
interested in the rig you used
for shooting these
long exposures.
Because I know one of the first
things I thought looking
at this when you had this device
was why you didn't get
some cooperation from the vendor
in terms of writing,
like, custom firmware for
the camera because
I know that's possible.
And my second question
is just more general.
Could you comment a little bit
about sort of the special
challenges of operating an SLR
in the middle of minus 40
degree Fahrenheit temperature
because that can't be like
walking down the street?
JEFF ORLOWSKI: No, it's
very, very different.
So Nikon sponsored the project,
and they gave us 25
Nikon D200s, which was one of
their leading cameras at the
time, their leading DSLR, for
what we could use en masse.
The timers that were available
from Nikon were timers that
kept the camera running 24/7.
So the power drain was very,
very high, and we couldn't
afford to use those timers
because the battery supply--
we couldn't bring enough
batteries out there to keep
that alive.
James talked with Nikon, for
sure, but their team wasn't
available to be designing
the hardware for us.
So James had worked with a guy
privately to build the
original intervalometer
to do that.
Nikon is a bit more
restrictive.
I believe, the Canon cameras are
a lot more open in terms
of fiddling with the firmware.
But I don't know if it's as
open for the Nikon system.
So that's about all I can
speak to on that.
Yeah?
Oh, I'm sorry.
Was there another question?
The long exposures.
AUDIENCE: I was looking for fun
anecdotes about, like--
JEFF ORLOWSKI: Oh, shooting?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
in 40-degree weather?
JEFF ORLOWSKI: Well, the worst
thing that would happen is
there was one time where we were
shooting on the beach,
and James had his camera in
a waterproof housing.
And he got so frustrated with
the bulk of the waterproof
housing and not being able to
operate it that he took it out
of the bag.
He kept shooting, then a rogue
wave came and splashed the
camera, fried the camera.
So he was a little upset that
day, just, like, wasting an
$8,000 camera.
But the biggest difficulty is
that they're not designed to
be used with layers and
layers of gloves.
Like, that's honestly the
biggest complication for the
still photo cameras and the
video cameras because you've
got, like, a Sony EX1 with these
little switches that you
flick with your fingernail,
typically, and these tiny,
little buttons that you, like,
you need your pinkie to press.
And when you have a mid-weight
glove, then a heavy glove, and
then a huge mitten on top of it,
being able to press any of
those things with accuracy
isn't possible.
The Sony cameras worked
amazingly well in the cold.
They held up.
The batteries held up.
You keep the batteries warm
inside your jacket pocket.
You swap them out kind of
regularly, and that keeps the
batteries going as
long as possible.
But I kept a little pen in my
coat or available, and I'd use
the pen in my mitten to, like,
poke at different buttons and
mess with little switches.
And that was really, a simple
device like that became, like,
so much easier to operate
than having to
take off your mitten.
Then you have to fold it in
half so snow doesn't get
inside, and you put it between
your legs or under your arm so
that snow doesn't get inside
your glove and you don't drop
it or lose it.
And now you've got still two
layers of gloves on, and it's
still too bulky to really
operate everything.
James would often take his
gloves off because he got so
frustrated, but he did get
frostnip a number of times on
his fingertips, yeah.
Yeah?
FEMALE SPEAKER: We have time
for one more question.
JEFF ORLOWSKI: Yeah?
Last question?
AUDIENCE: I was curious about
this one big glacier where you
had to move the camera because
it's receding.
Just how many years are
left on that glacier?
JEFF ORLOWSKI: How many years
are left on the glacier?
It's an interesting question.
It's a tough one for me to
answer specifically.
The glacier has gone through
incredible retreat.
In my lifetime, I think it's
retreated something like 13
miles, 12 to 14 miles,
in that range.
It is expected to continue
to retreat.
But based on the topography of
the land underneath, I believe
that there are some, like,
natural points where it will
no longer be ocean-terminating,
and it'll,
basically, kind of--
I'm not fully aware
of the long-term
projections on that one.
The glacier is called the
Columbia Glacier.
Our scientist, Tad Pfeffer,
has done a bunch
of papers on that.
The best I can advise is to look
up Tad Pfeffer and the
Columbia Glacier to see future
predictions on that because
I'm not a glaciologist.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Very quickly.
So I had to ask, too.
I noticed you had
some lead acid
batteries and solar panels.
Don't those freeze up?
Do they work at all?
JEFF ORLOWSKI: The lead acid
batteries were out there.
They performed poorly, but
they were, at some cases,
like, the only option
we had available.
There were times where
we couldn't--
I don't know if it can be done,
if Google can do this--
but we couldn't be shipping
batteries to Greenland.
We have to buy batteries locally
in Iceland and in
Greenland, so you're kind of
stuck with whatever you can
get locally.
There were times where we had
lead acid batteries in hiking
packs, and Adam was skiing
around with a lead acid
battery on his back.
He was the best skier of the
group, which is why he was
doing that.
I didn't want to volunteer
for that position.
But yeah, they didn't
perform very well.
James really tried to work
them out of the system.
We had one battery that
exploded in a
camera box in Alaska.
We just opened it, and
there was, like,
smoke inside the whole--
I mean, it had settled at that
point, but there was just the
dust lining the inside
of the pelican case.
But yeah, it was really
difficult to get the right
tools in those places.
AUDIENCE: You said you
cycled them out.
What were you using instead?
JEFF ORLOWSKI: There are
other batteries.
I don't know the battery
technology explicitly, but we
ended up using smaller--
effectively now, we just use,
like, motorcycle batteries.
And I don't know what kind
of technology behind the
batteries, but the solar
panels are smaller.
The batteries are smaller.
And they're at the point now
where they can last for a long
period of time because of the
way the timer is designed,
because they can hibernate
for so long.
AUDIENCE: All right,
thank you.
JEFF ORLOWSKI: Yeah, thanks.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I want
to thank you for--
JEFF ORLOWSKI: Yeah,
thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: --your
time today.
Jeff's going to be available if
you want to informally chat
with him, but we need
to close the talk.
And thank you so much.
JEFF ORLOWSKI: Yeah, thank
you, guys, very much.
[APPLAUSE]